you're a very talented and in-demand  actor you will work often in fact they  want to bring up the fact that you  screen tested for Ironman was that the  original Ironman or is it one of the  sequels that you screen tested for I  don't I don't I'm not aware of the ins  and outs I know that there was a day you  don't know in which you which when you  audition for just don't run the story  okay I know that wonderful actor Robert  Downey jr. and I we screened tested on  the same day and I'm still waiting to  hear back movies are huge yeah there be  a could be a real game-changer yeah I'm  dying this pub guessing you get it I'm  guessing is perfect where Downey jr. is  all wrong no these things they get  caught up in development yeah  yeah we'll see we'll see  you